bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission dans laquelle on aborde tous
les sujets sur tout ce qui fâche
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de la relance verte
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous ravis de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de ses caches on en
entend parler partout fait les mêmes
présente dans de nombreux plans de
sauvetage de l'économie chez la relance
verte
en quoi cela consiste exactement que
peut-on en attendre peut-on y voir un
véritable booster pour l'économie on va
en parler dans cette émission et pour
cela nous serons en deuxième partie avec
alain grandjean économiste président de
la fondation nicolas hulot et associé
fondateur du cabinet carbone 4 freiner
le réchauffement climatique tout en
stimulant la croissance voici a
grossièrement la finalité de ce que l'on
appelle communément la relance verte un
enjeu majeur pour les années à venir et
pourvoyeur de nombreux emplois pour
certains le tour de la relance verte
avec le tiroir cash d'antoine d'assas
[Musique]
c'est l'un des enjeux majeurs pour ce
qu'on appelle le monde d'après
reconstruire une économie plus
écologique plus verte sur les gravats
cne sera le colis de 19,1 en jeu tels
que l'onu a déclaré que si cette relance
était suffisamment écolo elle pourrait
permettre de freiner le réchauffement
climatique et réduire les émissions de
co2 prévu jusqu'en 2030 de 25%
et ce n'est pas tout puisque les ong wwf
france a dévoilé en juillet dernier un
scénario selon lequel elle pourrait
permettre de créer un million d'emplois
d'ici 2022 en france et 1,8 millions
d'ici 2030 dans les secteurs clé de la
rénovation des énergies renouvelables de
la mobilité de l'agriculture et du
tourisme la relance verte c'est
simplement faire en sorte que la
production et l'économie en général se
réinvente se transforme en prenant en
compte la protection de l'environnement
et la planète tout en créant de l'emploi
et en engrangeant de l'argent évidemment
sinon ce n'est pas une relance en somme
profiter de la crise pour tout revoir en
profondeur et pour cela pas 36 solutions
il faut investir et massivement wwf
préconise par exemple plusieurs dizaines
de milliards d'investissements sur dix
ans pour atteindre son objectif de
créations d'emplois le gouvernement lui
a également investi 30 milliards sur les
100 milliards de son plan de relance
sont dédiés à la transition écologique
bon c'est moins que la partie
compétitivité des entreprises qui
représentent 35 milliards ne faut pas
trop en demander non plus comme sur les
conditions contre la garantie de l'état
pour les fameux p.geo pas vraiment de
conditions contraignantes sur la
pollution imposé aux grosses entreprises
mauvaise pour l'environnement petit air
france ou renault juste des
recommandations en quelque sorte
décidément à défaut d'une relance verte
il faudra sans doute se contenter d'une
relance vert pâle voire d'une relance
tout court est encore olivier dans la
relance verte peut-on y voir est en
quelque sorte une réconciliation entre
écologie et économie
elle est belle ma lessive elle est belle
non c'est encore malheureusement un une
épreuve de communication c'est du
marketing donc des relance verte rouge
bleu vert jaune monsieur le maire est
devenu un spécialiste de la relance 1 1
et ils nous annoncent un petit jeu de
couleurs malheureusement si vous voulez
faudrait se poser des questions avant en
amont les bonnes questions
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire comme
relance verte quand vous avez une
économie qui est entièrement mondialisée
quand vous avez une économie de 2 2
de par exemple de l'habillement qui est
détruit des pour des dizaines de
millions de vêtements chaque année parce
que plus à la mode parce que
passé et ancienne série donc vous êtes
dans quelque chose qui aujourd'hui on
l'a vu avec la la le coc vide où on
était incapable en france de fabriquer
des masques et on les importe de la
chine
si vous pensez que c'est écologique moi
je veux bien mais ça ne l'est pas et
donc
las ce dont on discute et dans une autre
émission où on disait qu' il fallait
réindustrialiser la france ça ça serait
quelque chose d'intéressant pour pour
les que l'écologie et l'économie mais
malheureusement si vous laissez pas la
voie qui est choisie on va attribuer de
l'argent par exemple à des éoliennes
sachant très bien que ça ne marche pas
que c'est une aberration mais on va
continuer à distribuer de l'argent dans
là dedans on va parce que ça fait bien
on va fermer des centrales nucléaires
sans se poser la question pourquoi on va
les remplacer et probablement par du
charbon donc fait tout ça c'est c'est
les mots c'est de la com com tout ce qui
est fait depuis des années
malheureusement mois au moment de la
coop 21 j'avais dit vous allez voir il
va y avoir une coop 22 nov 23 une coque
24 et puis on va se retrouver dans dix
ans au probablement au même niveau en se
disant que ça serait bien de faire
quelque chose et malheureusement c'est
toujours ce qui se passe parce que
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas un seul pays
qui est concerné vous avez une économie
qui est mondialisée je vous le disais et
c'est pas quelque chose que monsieur
bruno le maire va changer à coup de
baguette magique
merci olivier on passe tout de suite à
la deuxième partie de cette émission
et cette semaine pour parler de la
relance verte nous sommes en liaison
avec alain grandjean bonjour monsieur
grandjean vous êtes économiste associé
fondateur du cabinet carbone 4 et
président de la fondation à nicolas
hulot merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
bonjour bonjour si beaucoup à vous de
m'avoir invité
alors monsieur grandjean après la crise
sanitaire après la crise économique et
l'heureux une relance verte sinon rien
oui ça c'est la moindre des choses il
faut bien s'entendre sur ce que veut
dire vers il ya deux grands problèmes
majeurs devant nous qui sont le
changement climatique qui est dû aux
émissions de co2 et d'autres gaz à effet
de serre donc une relance verte c'est
une relance qui favorise les modèles
économiques qui permet de réduire ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
défavorise des autres il ya un deuxième
grand problème qui est l'érosion de la
biodiversité donc une relance verte
idole ans qui est pas de nature à
aggraver ce problème là donc c'est non
seulement indispensable mais c'est une
condition de survie à moyen long terme
de l'espèce humaine
toutes les projections climatiques sont
sont malheureusement convergentes vers
l'idée que la planète pourrait subir une
augmentation de la température moyenne
planétaire d'ici 2100 2 3 4 5 6 degrés
ce qui est quelque chose qu'on m'a même
pas de facilités à imaginer tellement
les conséquences humaines sociales et
économiques sont majeurs donc je crois
qu'on n'a pas le choix et donc on
discutera de ce qui a été fait ce qui
est envisagé j'imagine dans cinq minutes
justement selon à l'onu ce une relance
verte ambitieuse pourrait permettre de
contenir la hausse des températures à 2
degrés avec une réduction des émissions
actuellement prévue pour 2030 de 25%
pour rester faisable et crédibles les
engagements de neutralité carbone
doivent être traduits d'urgence en
politique et en action forte à court
terme nous dit l'onu ce serait quoi pour
vous une relance verte viable et réussi
monsieur grandjean alors juste un tout
petit mot là la france dispose d'une
stratégie nationale bas carbone on n'est
pas les premiers à fait ça je pense que
l'angleterre l'a fait avant nous aidons
very ce qu'on appelle des budgets
carbone qu'ils sont
qui sont faits si on perd 2,5 ans et
donc on sait à peu près ce qu'il faut
faire et dans le plan actuel de du
gouvernement il ya une partie des choses
qui sont affaire qui sont imaginés donc
en gros il ya 2 il ya deux grands sujets
il ya le sujet de ce qu'on appelle
décarbonés l'énergie on a en france a la
chance d'avoir une électricité qui est
assez décarbonés avec du nucléaire
l'hydraulique un peu d'énergie
renouvelable et très peu de gaz presque
plus de charbon on va dire ça donc il
n'y a pas grand chose à faire donc on en
discutera aussi j'imagine peter en
revanche en dehors de l'électricité qui
représentent 25 % des émissions de la
consommation d'énergie finale tout pour
tout le reste on exactement comme les
autres pays donc on consomme du pétrole
et du gaz est donc le premier grand
sujet c'est de réduire l'usagé du
pétrole et du gaz dans nos gestes
permane quotidien qui sont la mobilité
qui sont le chauffage est évidemment qui
concerne l'industrie
le deuxième grand levier pour atteindre
cet objectif c'est de réduire notre
consommation d'énergie
c'était un peu paradoxal mais même bill
gates le 10 ans son dernier bouquin il a
mis du temps à le comprendre il n'y a
aucun scénario qui sont compatibles avec
un travail tort dit 2 degrés celle dont
parle de nuit donc celle qui respecte
l'accord paris où aucune trajectoire
n'est possible si on réduit pas notre
consommation d'énergie évidemment je
parle des pays occidentaux développés je
parle pas du yémen olivier même question
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
qu'a dit un monsieur grandjean je me
suis d'accord mais après il ya une à une
grosse marge entre ce qu'on devrait
faire et ça depuis des années ce qu'on
devrait faire et ce qu'on fait
réellement c'est à dire
là on parle de on vient de parler de
l'énergie nucléaire en ce qui concerne
l'électricité je vous rappelle que
aujourd'hui on a le double discours de
monsieur macron en même temps on ferme
des zus des des centrales nucléaires et
en même temps on veut le on voudrait
augmenter la la la l'offre de l'offre
d'électricité donc on sait que c'est pas
possible on sait que ça ne va pas aller
on sait que c'est pas de mettre quelques
gros ventilateur qui sont absolument pas
écologique qui ne marche pas qu'il faut
augmenter les prix de l'électricité qui
sont une bêtise absolue plutôt d'aller
fermer des centrales nucléaires qui sont
quand même plus intéressante pour avoir
une énergie propre
donc voilà c'est mais c'est toujours le
même discours c'est à dire
malheureusement oui il y à une urgence
oui il faudrait faire quelque chose mais
on ne s'en donne absolument pas les
moyens et on n'a pas du tout envie vous
disiez il faut baisser notre
consommation énergétique mais baisser
notre consommation énergétique
malheureusement ça veut aussi dire une
croissance qui sera très faible
or monsieur le maire nous explique qu'on
va rembourser toutes leurs bêtises là
depuis un an et demi avec une croissance
exceptionnellement fort alors moi je
voudrais qu'on m'explique comment on va
arriver à baisser la consommation
d'énergie et faire 6% de croissance de
l'autre côté ça va être compliqué non
olivier les consignes mans oui le petit
mot on parlera je propose qu'on parle de
la question du nucléaire a peu après
c'est pas pro botté en touche c'est
juste que ça me paraît pas dans le
paysage la priorité je redis à
l'électricité c'est 25% de l'énergie
finale donc les grands priorité c'est
réduire la consommation d'énergie dans
les bâtiments et logements puisque c'est
de très loin le premier poste et ensuite
en matière de co2 et d'énergie c'est de
réduire la les émissions de co2 dans le
transport sur là où il n'y a pas de
contradiction du tout entre et dont je
suis évidemment pas d'accord et ce qui
vient débit entre l'activité économique
je vais parler de la croissance juste
après mais l'activité économique et
l'efficacité énergétique dans les
bâtiments c'est que s'il ya une sorte d'
activités économiques bien connu c'est
dans le domaine de la rénovation des
bâtiments donc on rénove de toute façon
chaque année pas mal de la timone de
gens là le but du jeu c'est de faire des
rénovations dites énergétique se
transforme ces bâtiments en beaucoup
moins de consommation de sorte qu'ils
consomment beaucoup moins donc ça c'est
des travaux c'est des travaux de
d'entreprises du bâtiment c d changement
de moyen de chauffage cd remplacement
des chaudières à fuel ya encore trois
quatre pillon il s'agit des remplacer
tout ça c'est de l'industrie qui a
derrière évidemment j'achète beaucoup de
l'argument de la rien du cerisier
ouverte on va en parler après
deuxièmement vous avez parlé de 6% de
croissance je pense que vous êtes un
petit peu optimiste chéri et moi qui
l'ait die
c'est monsieur lemay mais monsieur le
maire s'il sait très bien qui sait pas
calculer donc non mais ça dort mais on
va dire on va dire deux choses on va
dire il ya un petit effet rebond c'est à
dire que tout le monde attend à ce que
de suite à une année 2020 avec une
baisse de pib très élevé en demi pour
cent on retrouve
la situation ex ante et donc sa demande
évidemment un petit passage par une
augmentation du pib mais dans la suite
des événements je crois pas du tout je
crois pas qu'on fera beaucoup de
croissance
mais ce qu'on va faire c'est ça le but
d'une relance verte et de créer des
emplois dans des activités qui sont
compatibles avec les enjeux dans que
gerra petter est de compenser les
destructions d'emplois dont vous n'avez
pas parlé tout à l'heure mais qui sont
extrêmement importants là je comprends
très bien les chiffrages du wwf et de
tous ceux qui disent on va créer de
l'emploi je pense qu'il faut pas tromper
les français là gm est un tout petit peu
caché un peu les pieds dans le plat
il y aura aussi des destructions je
prends l'exemple le plus symbolique qui
est l'industrie automobile je pense
qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de débats entre
les expériences sur le fait que la bonne
solution on dans les 10 20 ans qui
viennent c'est de remplacer les voitures
thermiques par des voitures électriques
ça va dépasser des emplois savard en
détruire parce qu'on va avoir besoin
d'au moins deux garagistes les voitures
à moteur électrique sont plus faciles à
entretenir que les voitures thermiques
les industriels devront sans doute avoir
besoin de moins de moins de temps de
travail pour faire des moteurs
électriques mais on ne compte pas ti il
faut qu'on crée des emplois dans les
voitures électriques et notamment dans
les batteries ça va pas se faire tout
seul dans une compétition internationale
mais contrairement à une idée reçue la
france a pas du tout la possibilité est
là dessus il faut s'en donner les moyens
et de volonté moi je partage l'idée
qu'il faut faire de l'un des
réalisations verte qu'il faut créer des
emplois de même assez active et les gens
du textile était est très très bon j'ai
trouvé que vous avez cités c'est vrai
que continuer textile comme on le fait
aujourd'hui c'était un désastre
ce qui est par rock on vit pas en france
mais qu'on vide avoue ses produits et
pas de raison ce soit une fatalité
donc faut un peu de volonté ça se joue
pas qu'en france ça se joue évidemment
aussi au niveau européen
mais si on va marquer une courte pause
on vient dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine la
relance verte et pour cela nous sommes
en liaison avec alain grandjean
économiste et président de la fondation
nicolas hulot
olivier on l'a dit relance verte c'est
un terme que l'on entend partout
il est présent dans de nombreux plans de
relance notamment celui de la france
pour rappel ce dernier se compose de
trois volets dont injustement justement
consacré à l'écologie avec 30 milliards
d'euros c'est le volet le moins doté à
titre de comparaison le volet
compétitivité des entreprises lui hérite
de 35 milliards tout comme la cohésion
sociale et territoriale d'où ma question
peut-on parler ici d'une véritable
relance verte ou est ce un plan de
relance classique avec un volet vert
c'est une bonne question
moi je dirais que c'est mieux que ce que
n'ont jamais fait des gouvernements
précédents donc faut pas cracher dans la
soupe
je le dirai deuxièmement que le volet
cohésion sociale il est il est quand
même bienvenu
je crois pas qu'on peut opposer écologie
économie j'ai essayé de montrer rapide
en valeur mais on peut par plus opposer
écologie et social sert que si des
ambitions écologiques se faisait dans un
pays dévasté socialement notamment à
cause des copies d'un mais pas que je ne
pense pas qu'on arriverait très loin le
la révolte des gilet jaune l'a montré
maintenant est-ce que c'est suffisant
moi la principale critique que je serai
à ce plan de relance français mais
j'avais aussi au niveau européen c'est
sa durée
j'ai prendre un seul exemple donc la
durée c'est en gros 2 en 1 pour la faire
récemment j'ai prendre un seul exemple
c'est le report modal des camions vers
le vert le fret ferroviaire situé à un
échec français ça fait depuis 2007 combi
qu'on va favoriser le transport de
marchandises sur le ferroviaire versus
les camions en france et les français
sont plutôt pour en fait parce que les
camions sur les routes
c'est un peu seulement tout le monde
c'est bon proxima d'éviter ces camions
parce qu'ils émettent du co2 c'est très
dur de changer la motorisation des
grands camions c'est beaucoup plus dur
que le poids les voitures bon c'est pas
en deux ans confesse cet ce transfert
modal du routier vers le fret il faut
des années d
mais parce qu'il faut les habitudes soit
changé il faut qu'ils désinvestissement
très significatif dans la branche fret
ferroviaire de la sncf on n'y est pas du
tout donc deux ans c'est trop court et
moelleux 35 milliards pourquoi pas jean
rémy aurait volontiers mis un peu plus
mais c'est pas vraiment la question là
ta question c'est vraiment la durée il
faut il faut beaucoup de temps beaucoup
de continuité de persévérance j'ai pris
l'exemple du fret ferroviaire je prêtais
de prendre aussi l'exemple du logement
il ya des dizaines de millions de
logements à rénover on annonce des
chiffres de type 500 mille par an n'est
pas du tout et donc il faut beaucoup
beaucoup d'années pour y arriver et donc
c'est des plans longs qu'il faut mettre
en oeuvre et pas juste des pichenettes
olivier je vais très méchant c'est quand
la date des élections c'est 2022
donc ce plan ne sert qu'à ça à mon avis
c'est à dire à donner quelques caution à
aux écologistes
histoire de se ramasser quelques
quelques voix je vais très très méchant
mais je pense que c'est c'est plus ça si
les demandes et pas un politique d'avoir
une vision long terme
le politique sa vision c'est la
prochaine élection
et là il se trouve que à la prochaine
élection monsieur mac ronces et 2022
donc ne lui demandez pas d'aller
anticiper quelque chose au-delà de ces
élections parce que ça serait peine
perdue
oui vous avez raison que les lécheurs de
2022 et dans paysage c'est complètement
clair n'empêche que il aurait pu dire
que c'était
dans son idée le démarrage d'un plan de
long terme parce que ça préempter une
discussion qui aura aux présidentielles
le prochain candidat présidentiel s'ils
s'amusent à ne pas annoncer une
poursuite donne une amplification de ce
type de programme je pense qu'il aura
des ennuis pour récupérer les voix
écolos alors on en vient à ces chiffres
du wwf-france les ong a proposé au
gouvernement un scénario de relance
verte avec à la clé un million d'emplois
liées à la transition écologique d'ici
2022 et 1,8 million à l'horizon 2030
dans des secteurs comme la rénovation
les énergies renouvelables l'agriculture
ou encore le tourisme
un scénario qui a tout de même un coût
14 milliards d'euros par an jusqu'en
en plus des 15 milliards promis par
emmanuel macron sur deux ans puis 29
milliards jusqu'en 2030 d'un point de
vue financement est ce que c'est tenable
monsieur grandjean oui alors moi j'ai
pas j'ai pas de jets pas de doute que ce
soit à d'habiles ya une grosse
discussion aujourd'hui au niveau
européen qui est celle qu'on ferme les
règles des déficits bon chez les
économistes pensent qu'il ya un bon
consensus sur l'idée qu'on est allé trop
vite à la consolidation budgétaire comme
on dit après la crise de 2008 2009 en
europe
versus qui s'est passé aux états unis où
les états unis ont été beaucoup plus
précautionneux ils ont laissé les filets
difficile plus longtemps bon là on a un
nouveau président des états unis joe
biden qui est extrêmement ambitieux sur
son plan de relance américain
donc moi je pense qu'il ya pas de règle
absolue
on a un très bon économiste ancien chef
économiste du fmi qui nous dit on ne
fait pas quel est le bon le dit le
niveau maximal possible d'une dette
publique ça reste affaire de
circonstance et d'opportunités donc je
pense que de ce côté-là il aida marge
bien autrement gay de la marge
c'est que
les marchés financiers sanctionne pas du
tout les dettes les dettes souveraines
donc je pense qu'on met dans une très
bonne situation est depuis plusieurs
années pour faire ce type
d'investissement il ya eu un retour
économique y est évident et le recours
économie qui est évident c'est le fait
qu'on va baisser notre facture
énergétique on va aller pêcher dans un
achat pétrole et de gaz
olivier pour vous ce financement et si
tonale à bas aujourd'hui tout
financement étonnant puisque toute façon
vous détenez les clés de la planche à
billets et que vous faites ce que vous
voulez donc c'est nabeul bien évidemment
on le paiera cher
bien évidemment aussi mais c'est nabeul
puisque on fait ça depuis 2008 je vous
rappelle depuis 2008 on a sorti la
grosse cavalerie on a enchaîné les
quantitative easing
alors là la bce a mis un petit peu de
temps à s'y mettre mais maintenant elle
met les bouchées doubles 1 le bilan de
la bce explose et est donc oui c'est
tenable parce que aujourd'hui ça ne veut
plus ça ne repose sur rien ça ne veut
plus rien dire donc on pourrait aussi
mettre 200 milliards de plus sur le plan
de relance vers toute façon vous savez
très bien que au final on fera en sorte
de ne pas le payer alors soit par de
l'hyperinflation chute de la monnaie
écroulement de la monnaie plutôt et soit
par un défaut de paiement
ça arrivera mais c'est pas grave c'est
pas grave puisque toute façon je vous
dis il suffit de descendre à la cave
d'imprimer un petit peu plus sain et
puis d'annoncer des chiffres qui ne
seront évidemment jamais tenu le 1
million d'emplois créés et je veux bien
qu'on se retrouve d'ici deux ans et
qu'on en reparle
vous verrez que c'est c'est toujours
décès des promesses politiques monsieur
denjean a juste pour terminer un mois
sur le nucléaire dont vous parlez oui
juste avant tout puisque c'est un sujet
de passion en france donc il est inexact
de dire que les éoliennes ne marche pas
parce que l'angleterre qui est un
exemple très réussie de sortie du
charbon un recours très significatif aux
éoliennes offshore donc je pense qu'un
arbitrage politique il n'y a pas de
débat trop sur le fait que si on fait du
nucléaire ou si on fait des énergies
renouvelables dans tous les cas tir il
faut du fer du bas carbone donc faut
éviter le recours au charbon mais ça en
valait fermés en france y'a pas de
problème pour éviter limiter le recours
aux gaz peut-être juste au moment où on
a des pointes lillers il faut développer
l'hydraulique qui a encore un peu de
marge sur leicester et donc le débat
nucléaire éolienne solaire et métal
biométhane il est toujours mal posée
parce qu'on compare le nucléaire anciens
ou nucléaire futur je rappelle les
ordres de grandeur quand même le
nucléaire anciens c'est celui qu'on a
aujourd'hui il est effectivement pas
cher il à 40,50 euros le mégawattheure
le nucléaire futur c'est à dire quand
ils n'ont quant à eux rien à voir
puisque aujourd'hui flamanville est
toujours pas sorti de cure pas le livret
est toujours pas respecté les ordres de
grandeur c'est plutôt de entre 100 et
150 euros mégawattheure aujourd'hui les
mêmes ordres de grandeur nous disent que
les solutions renouvelables sont plutôt
moins cher même en intégrant les surplus
de batterie et de stockage donc
aujourd'hui il ya une
discussions techniques très profond mais
qui se ramène pas la caricature que j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure il ya un énorme
travail qui est fait par les
spécialistes pour pouvoir dire d'ici un
ou deux ans est ce que on peut vraiment
éviter de construire de nouvelles
centrales nucléaires
avec le parc existant et le
développement des énergies renouvelables
moi je fais partie des gens qui pensent
que c'est jouable
je pense qu'il faut bénéficier se tirer
bénéfice du parc géré actuelle pour
faire cette transition qui prendra du
temps mais je fais pas du tout partie
des gens qui font pensent que c'est une
hérésie économique
je pense qu'au contraire ces aînés
régionales sont beaucoup moins cher que
ce qu'on prend et d'ailleurs je suis pas
le seul et la france ne sera pas le seul
c'est très évidemment la solution dans
l'immense majorité du monde
énormément de pays qui peuvent pas se
payer nucléaire pour plein de raisons
donc que les frappes et consorts parle
de toute façon merci beaucoup à alain
grandjean d'avoir été à parmi nous dans
cette émission gerber chef économiste et
président de la fondation nicolas hulot
olivier on continue avec les questions
cash
et on commence tout de suite avec la
question de caroline mercier si on nous
rebat les oreilles avec l'épargné qui
serait au sommet pourtant avec le
chômage autour de moi beaucoup de monde
à liquider jusqu'au per qu'on est il
réellement les pannes qui grossit
n'est-elle pas l' épargne dormantes du
papy boom
alors il n'y a plus il ya plusieurs
choses d'abord dans les parle bas vous
avez la hausse de l' de la bourse et
donc quelques quelques grands capitaines
d'industrie qui enfin ou de deux
sociétés du cac 40 qui en effet ce sont
bien enrichie ces derniers temps ensuite
vous avez une épargne de précaution
c'est à dire que le type qui sait qu'il
va perdre son boulot toute façon à la
sortie ou quand on empêche de travailler
aujourd'hui oui il fait de leppard mais
il fait pas de l'epargne pour se ruer
dans les boutiques le jour où on sera
libéré il fait de l'epargne simplement
parce qu'il sait qu'il va avoir un ou
deux ans probablement à financer sans
forcément retrouver du boulot tout de
suite
et voilà mes donc
ce les questions qui se posent
actuellement sur comment peut-on se pour
le gouvernement comment peut-on
s'approprier cette épargne c'est ce que
je vous disais plusieurs fois c'est à
dire que en effet il va falloir payer
leur bêtise et donc il va falloir saisir
l'argent des français
d'une manière ou d'une autre merci
olivier c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de votre fidélité on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro en attendant pour voir ou revoir
nos précédents de ses émissions rendez
vous sur notre site internet à l'adresse
rt france point tv et n'oubliez pas de
poser toutes vos questions à olivier
avec le hashtag rt cash sur les réseaux
sociaux olivier c'est à vous de conclure
eh bien écoutez si on en croit notre
invité il va falloir qu'ils aient des
ventilateurs absolument tous les mètres
carrés en france pour remplacer les
centrales nucléaires